well you spoke to us an hour ago and
things that were calm
uh they have turned very very quickly a
very violent
series of confrontations here on the um
just outside the al-aqsa
compound area the area of the al-aqsa
mosque let's move down here
and we can show you the situation here
the israeli police are arresting people
uh as they try to clear an area an area
where where
where the palestinians were praying for
their morning their morning prayer at
the end
of the daily ramadan fast we've seen
stun grenades being thrown we've seen
tear gas being fired and i could just
see the water cannon
just through there as you look out
towards the mount of olives there
from the lions gate here in the old city
the water cannon
are getting prepared that's a water
cannon which fires what's known as skunk
which is a rancid liquid
that takes days yeah we'll just move
over here it takes days to
get off your skin and your clothes today
is jerusalem day
it's what israelis believe is the day
that uh
their city was unified remembering the
day the city was unified back in 1967
clashes were always to be expected
clashes were always to be expected on
today confluence of events
means that it is extremely tense with
the worst clashes that we've seen
for quite a few years
it seems mark that this is a situation
that that could escalate
yeah yeah sorry to interrupt you steve
we were talking to one
man a palestinian who was in the al-aqsa
mosque a little bit earlier on
he says that the israeli soldiers were
there
and that they provoked this that they
started
attacking the protesters now i can't
tell you
if that's right because we're not
allowed into the the compound area
itself what i do know is that through
the course of the night
palestinians had stockpiled rocks in the
in the compound area because they
expected
that jewish nationalists would try
around there there's someone
injured just coming out the jewish
nationalists would try and
access the alaksa mosque area which the
jews
is known as temple mount their holiest
the holiest
area for judaism so it's a very very
tense situation all around
i can also say that last night when we
were at the um
uh when we were at the damascus gate
area yesterday there i continue to tell
you that the
the police aggression was unprovoked the
palestinians who were gathering for the
end of
of their fast yesterday at the damascus
gate were simply sitting quietly
when the police arrived with mounted
mounted police and with the water cannon
and began firing into the damascus
gate area that i can tell you as an
eyewitness
was unprovoked the response was water
bottles plastic water bottles thrown
by some of the young palestinians um so
yeah a very very tense day the british
government um
clearly with a with a complicated
history here in this region uh has
released a statement
uh james cleverley the foreign office
minister said this morning that both
sides need to
to calm to de-escalate uh and so that
that
ramadan can come to an end uh peacefully
uh there are people
stephen talking about the prospect of a
third intifada
a third palestinian uprising of course
the first two
were over a decade ago uh horrendous
bloodshed back then since then
jerusalem israel palestine has been in
somewhat
of a stalemate a stalemate that i think
has allowed the world to kind of forget
the problems that are going on here but
i think that stalemate obscures
attention that never went away
and sparks like this really reignited i
don't think we're at a stage yet where
we could talk about the prospects of a
third intifada
although some believe we are but i think
we're close
a very difficult situation the politics
is extremely complicated
an entirely dysfunctional israeli
government with benjamin netanyahu
the prime minister for well over a
decade now trying desperately to hang on
to power and in doing so
he is trying to attract far far right
israelis
giving the far-right israeli street if
you like
a certain legitimacy to push their their
settlement
agenda into the west bank and for the
palestinians well they haven't had any
elections since 2005 in the west bank
again a politics that is um uh well
corrupt and uh letting the people down
all the time so we'll monitor
the day but it's just gone 9 a.m
and already i've seen scores of people
injured